e aí galera que assistir o canal como é
que uma salva de hoje é olha na rede
balançar
e aí galera que assistir o canal tudo
com vocês como é que vocês tanto é que
vocês estão sentindo hoje quero saber
como é consertar hoje nesse dia cara eu
to feliz estou tão feliz que eu comeria
um pônei assado agora um suco de
criancinha matinê classificado pra
galera é o último dia do vida onde estou
sem palavras e olha vou contar porque é
ouvida por quem não sabendo venda é blog
é verdadeiro fazer um fórum vídeo é
todos o santos dia de abrir lá vai eu
fazer ouvida ea mostram o que eu quero é
ser tanto diving a galera não é fácil 30
dias seguir todo dia você ter uma idéia
diferente uma coisa nova uma coisa cada
dia está se superando não é fácil
contigo 9018 eu falei assim não acabou
para ir pra mim pra mim isso a gota
d'água pra mim tudo é pra mim não
consigo além de ficar pensando nesse
vídeo aqui poderia estar fazendo ele em
outro dia e dá mais via mas assim que eu
sempre pensei assim o faça o vídeo eu
faço vídeo eu faço dois vídeos por
semana cada vez dá 200 mil viu trazer o
que eu falei não vou fazer todo dia leva
a bolsa eu achei que pôs vídeo que ela
ia ficar em torno de 30.000 e 40.000
ouvir que vocês gostaram de maio então
você gostar de madhu zetas em venda de
200 mil te ver de 150 mil mas sabe que
você não vê nada serviu que a gente a
gente nem sempre é engraçado a gente nem
sempre há de bom o agente nem sempre
acorda acorda assim sabe com um à
vontade de fazer vídeo a gente faz nem
por que tem que fazer mais
esses dias que a gente tá brava gente
deixa passar esse dia que emita um e
deixa pra lá
deixa pra gravar outro dia ou grava 20
de uma vez sim
ia no outro dia mas não venda não duvida
todo dia tinha de gravar eu magoei bom
todo dia tinha que teve a vamos achar
que eu não sei de quem seja e quem tá
hora o tempo está aqui porque tem que
ter vídeo no ar vão patah lugar não
posso ir porque eu tô fazendo ver
palavra idiota fazendo ver todo dia por
isso que vocês viram que alguns vídeo
estava com sem gravar outros vídeo outro
dia estava b outro vídeo estava muito
muito triste com a impressão que eu tive
que explicar vocês tudo que está
acontecendo você me ajudar e se vê duda
e se vê de serviu pra mostrar como a
gente é humano como agente a pessoa
normal com todos vocês a corda incomodou
sempre de barriga sente tristeza fica
alegre tenta ficar calado e 90 18 falei
cara doido é certo e falei vou papa mas
o compromisso não era comigo meu
compromisso com vocês até agora até
agora nesse momento estava nem sai de
gente que fala cara o vida foi a melhor
terapia que tudo fez para encarar o
verdão melhorou minha vida sempre assim
encara o verdão fez isso fez aquilo que
ficou sabendo que está fazendo bem
alguém bom continuavam na tora vamos
prêmios pensamento vamos premiar as
idéias vão escrever tudo vamos tentar
2007 tinha dia que eu falava assim
encara hoje eu vou gravar sobre as
capivaras voador com a tarde tanto mundo
dos galápagos que não tinha idéia de não
via nada na minha cabeça nada nada sabe
quanto espreme espreme até o último
coisas neurônio do teu servo não sai
nelson de laranja aquele venda que eu
fiz um nome do vídeo venda no seu ver da
então número um vídeo bem 11 vídeo muito
muito cara aquele vídeo ben ali dentro
daquele vídeo animou ea minha mais
profunda desgraça que teve no meu
pensamento a maior falta de criatividade
da minha vida
foi naquele eu tinha gravado aquela
imagem não sabia o que estava fazendo a
minha cabeça eu fiquei doido tô o
banheiro eo banheiro achava que tinha
uma câmera migravam eu ia fazer comida
achava que tinha uma câmera migravam
etanol cresce e me ligava o meu filho aí
como é que a alma possa conversar não
porque eu tenho que terminar a venda de
hoje a bebê da mãe nem sabe
não é um projeto desafio e estou fazendo
não sei que meu filho tem que prestar
atenção em você tem que se alimentar não
sei que estou nem dormindo dormir
direito eu acho que o terror pior do que
você dormir já pensando o que vai fazer
no tiro gravavam veio falar meu deus e
amanhã vai ser o que devem vir e vai
levar a cabo e vai acabamos acabando
nessa cama e me deixar ir bem andando na
linha grande assim e eu pensava todo dia
hoje não vai treinar hoje não vai ter
hoje não vai terminar última hora fazer
alguma hoje dava sol e tem gente que
está acompanhando desde o primeiro vita
todo de assistir todo de doido esse tipo
de fã do tipo de fã que eu amo menino
gosto nem por que eu boto no youtube
porque o bota o youtube para assistir se
você está assistido ou assistir pra mim
já tá bom eu nunca cheguei falo nunca
fala essas coisas meu canal pra você não
vou falar agora só nesse mês dúvida nós
tivemos 20 milhões de minutos assistido
foi mais de 1.300.000 gostei de você e
toda vez que o psd por intenção boa fico
feliz demais eu prometo eu prometo que
vai voltar os vídeos antigo nem um
jeitinho na minha casa blogs em mim e
tal música punk a ostentação tudo tudo
tudo vai voltar ao normal eu só quero
agradecer a todos vocês que acompanharam
todos os vídeos muito obrigado mesmo em
uma caminhada muito grande você fazer
vídeo no youtube é fácil não as pessoas
te xinga pessoa fala que tá um lixo mas
graças a deus eu tenho vocês que além de
gostar quando um fala mal você me
defendi a esse pacote fora dani você é
um exército em um deserto é tentar da
gente tem poder valeu mesmo eu quero que
você comente aqui embaixo qual foi o
melhor vida que você assistiu ao forno
mercados esses meus vídeos do vídeo que
você gostou quanto no embarque para ver
como obrigado mesmo e lógico como é o
último venda aquele último gostei no
verão a galera agora vou descansar ou
descansam o nem dormir direito
dormiu um mês um mês um beijo em dormir
não quer também são android mas eu tô um
mês
o meu domínio totalmente desregulado eu
estou acordado aqui cinco horas da manhã
eu durma com três da tarde chega
acordado em 17 da noite acordou 10 hora
meu deus é loucura demais e eu espero
que vocês me entendam também é isso aí
muito obrigado e muito obrigado muito
obrigado mesmo que o paulo